Speaker 1: Yesterday, we talked a little bit
about how Joe Biden's visit to Ukraine on
Presidents Day, can you imagine, has been
used to say, well, he really should have been
at the border or he really, really should
have been in East Palestine?
I was told very politely by people I was mispronouncing
it yesterday.
This is the problem when I only read news
as opposed to watch it.
I don't know that it's pronounced Palestine
instead of Palestine.
Okay.
The argument that some of these right wingers
were making was, Oh, it was the wrong day
to go to Ukraine instead of the border or
to Ohio, the brains of a lot of these folks
continue to break endlessly.
Don Junior made the argument that it was particularly
bad that Biden went to Ukraine on President's
Day because Russia is to blame for the train
derailments.
I mean, it's it's all making very little sense.
Speaker 2: Hey, we have derailment.
Speaker 1: After train derailment with.
Speaker 2: Environmental disasters.
No one asking if it's maybe the Russians retaliating
after the article came out about us possibly
attacking the Nord Stream two pipeline.
Speaker 1: Okay.
That article has been widely debunked and
it's based on almost nothing.
The article has been ridiculed widely and
has been widely debunked.
We actually know with almost total certainty
what happened with the train derailment.
There are hot box detectors which are recommended
to be placed every 20 or 25 miles to determine.
Is something getting too hot on the train,
a bearing or other things?
There is video footage that suggests that
20 miles out of East Palestine, there was
already a fire on the train.
There was no such detector there to notify
the train crew as a result, because it is
not a requirement to have those hot box detectors.
We ended up with what we ended up with.
And Don, just talking about Russia.
You know, the Trumps love to say, why does
everybody talk about Russia?
He's talking about Russia when it makes no
sense to be talking about Russia.
And it's all because their brains are broken.
Also important to mention, over time, train
derailments per passenger per mile traveled
have continued to decline in the United States.
They're not actually up.
There are still too many train derailments
and they are unfortunately regular thing,
if you count train and subway and all of these
different things.
But derailments have actually declined.
So that's don Jr.
Ben SHAPIRO, on the other hand, suggests with
no evidence that the air raid sirens in the
background of Biden's visit to Ukraine were
stage managed.
They were staged for Biden's visit.
Speaker 3: A clip came out of Joe Biden walking
through Kiev with Vladimir Zelensky.
And the air raid sirens go off.
It's curious.
It's weird.
They don't even break.
Nobody.
Even nobody, even for a second in the press
pool and looks around like normally when the
air raid sirens go off.
And I've been in countries when air raid sirens
have gone off.
I mean, like I was in Jerusalem last year,
the Eritreans in actually go off in Jerusalem,
but they you were checking your phone consistently
for like, where are the rocket attacks falling?
Speaker 1: Isn't that the best?
He goes, I've been in countries where air
raid sirens are going off.
Like, for example, I was in Jerusalem, actually,
the air raid sirens weren't going off, but
I was keeping a really close eye on my phone.
That's it's ridiculous.
Speaker 3: People tend to have a tendency
when when a giant noise goes off, it says
you should get to shelter.
People tend to at least look in the air.
In this book, nobody looks in the air.
There's a reason for that as well.
Explain in just a moment.
It was Joe Biden with Vladimir Zelensky yesterday
walking through give.
Why them?
Well, there's only a couple of problems back
left.
One, and nobody looks in the air while the
air raid sirens are going off.
The second is that a CNN reporter then went
on the air and he's like, oh, yeah, By the
way, we haven't heard near returning here
for like five weeks.
Literally the only moment I've heard an air
raid siren the last five weeks has been when
Joe Biden walked outside with Vladimir Zelensky,
which sort of suggests that what they really
wanted was a follow up.
A big brave Joe Biden, dark aviator glasses,
dark Brandon walking around, keep with the
air raid sirens going off like Winston Churchill
in the rubble of London or something.
Speaker 1: All right.
So there's Ben Shapiro's incisive commentary.
The air raid sirens were certainly staged.
And then here's FOX News reporter, deporter
reporter Peter Doocy, who didn't like the
tone, I guess, of the Biden speech.
And.
Okay, let's listen.
Speaker 4: President Biden disagrees with
that and we expect him to expand on that theme
later on today at this speech, which should
start in a few minutes.
And it's not the solemn set of remarks that
we were kind of told to expect based on the
existential threats that he sees has almost
a campaign rally feel like like if they were
having a campaign rally for democracy.
Speaker 1: HARRIS Wow, how terrible that would
be.
Let's rally for democracy, which is in peril
and endanger the world over.
So this wasn't it wasn't a sad enough event
for Peter Doocy.
The atmosphere was like to rally, like in
favor of democracy, which seems, by the way,
like a pretty worth worthy cause to me.
So they don't even know what sorts of criticisms
to make at this point in time, because the
truth is Biden looked strong by going to Ukraine.
So they go, well, President's Day was the
wrong day to go or he should have been at
the derailment or he should have been at the
border or the atmosphere should have been
sadder or the air raid sirens were staged
or Russia did the derailment or whatever the
case may be, for which it's conspiracies and
whining.
Ultimately, what we are getting from the right
at this point in time, their brains are cracking
like an egg and breaking.
And I don't expect this to change at all any
time soon.
Meanwhile, Trump spending time on truth social
posting about Ron DeSantis and almost nobody's
paying attention.
So you can understand why they're upset and
why they're scrambling and why they are so
triggered.
Later in the program, we will look at sort
of more these are slightly more cartoonish
reactions.
We're going to look at kind of the scarier
reactions from some on the right to the news
over the last 72 hours.
Stay with us.
Remember, we can really use your help getting
to 2 million YouTube subscribers.
Go to YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.
Slam that subscribe button.
We appreciate it.